I couldn't bring myself to say hey  you've got a big booty and you're my  favorite well that's why  I asked and this is another  Redemption American Pie uh Pulp Fiction  if you look at the top movies of 2021 it  is literally uh other than Top Gun the  highest grossing movie was Sonic the  Hedgehog 2. so we need some political  incorrectness we need somebody saying  you got a big booty and I know that  that's no not the nicest thing and  probably not the you know uh you know  it's a little Unbecoming of a gentleman  at the same time it is harmless I am  complimenting her she is Jimmy from the  Block I mean I know she's not Jennifer  Lopez but she's from that you don't  think she's ever been cat called by a  construction worker I get cat called in  New York City